RECKONING.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE"."
OVER THE PAST FEW WEEKS, I’VE
HEARD FROM SOME OF THE SMARTEST
MEDICAL MINES IN AMERICA ABOUT
BOTH THE NATURE OF THIS HIDEOUS
VIRUS AND THE MOST PROMISING
TREATMENTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
UNDER INVESTIGATION.
BECAUSE OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE
BEEN DEALING WITH THIS LONGER
AND ON A LARGER SCALE, SOME OF
THEM ARE HEAD OF US ON FINDING
THE BEST DRUG TREATMENT BUREAU
ON MONDAY, I TOLD YOU ABOUT TWO
OF THEM.
THE ANTIMALARIAL DRUG
CHLOROQUINE AND ITS SISTER
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, MANUFACTURED
BY SANOFI LABS.
TODAY IT WAS BROUGHT AT THE
WHITE HOUSE PRESS BRIEFING.
>> RESEARCHERS HAVE HAD SOME
LUCK WITH HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE,
AND SHORTENING THE DURATION OF
DISEASE.
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT MIGHT BE
IN THE ARSENAL OF THERAPEUTICS
IN THE UNITED STATES?
>> I THINK WE ARE EXPLORING
EVERY ONE OF THOSE ISSUES.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT LOOK
REALLY GOOD AGAINST THE VIRUS,
THAT MAY LOOK GOOD IN SMALL
ANIMALS, AND THEN DON’T HAVE AN
IMPACT IN HUMANS.
OF COURSE, THERE’S ALWAYS
ANECDOTAL REPORTS, AND WE ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW MANY
ANECDOTAL REPORTS EQUALLY REAL,
SCIENTIFIC BREAKTHROUGHS.
>> Laura: I’M NOT SURE WHAT
SHE MEANT BY "ANECDOTAL," BUT
THE ROUND FRENCH RESEARCHER AND
INFECTIOUS DISEASE SPECIALIST
DIDIER RAOULT WAS TASKED BY THE
FRENCH GOVERNMENT TO LOOK INTO
CURES FOR COVID-19 AND HE
DESCRIBED HIS RESULTS YESTERDAY
AS PROMISING.
GOOD NEWS.
ANY VIDEO POSTED ON THE
INTERNET, HE SAID THAT THE FIRST
BATCH OF 24 COVID-19 COVID-19 PA
HAD TREATED WITH THE DRUG
CHLOROQUINE HAD SEEN A RAPID AND
EFFECTIVE SPEEDING UP OF THEIR
HEALING PROCESS AND A SHARP
DECREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THEY REMAIN CONTAGIOUS.
YES.
CHINA AND SOUTH KOREA, THE
COUNTRIES HARDEST HIT WITH
COVID-19, THEY HAVE ALREADY
DEVELOPED GUIDELINES FOR
PHYSICIANS WHO ARE PRESCRIBING
THE USE OF CHLOROQUINE AND
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
AS TREATMENT OPTIONS.
IT’S NOT JUST IN ANIMALS AND IN
THE LAB.
CHLOROQUINE WAS CHOSEN AFTER
CHINA DID SEVERAL SCREENING
ROUNDS OF THOUSANDS OF EXISTING
DRUGS.
CHLOROQUINE IS UNDERGOING
FURTHER TRIALS AND MORE THAN TEN
HOSPITALS THERE NOW.
WHATEVER THE PRESIDENT HAS TO DO
TO CUT RED TAPE AND BRING CLEAR
TREATMENT OPTIONS SUCH AS
THIS -- AND ALSO PREVENTATIVE --
TO AMERICANS, HE NEEDS TO DO IT.
AND I BET IT IS COMING SOON.
WHICH BRINGS ME TO MY NEXT
POINT: DEMANDING TOTAL
COOPERATION AND OPENNESS FROM
CHINA, OR ELSE.
IN A PANDEMIC, IT IS ESSENTIAL
THAT OUR HEALTH EXPERTS WORK
COOPERATIVELY WITH OTHER
COUNTRIES AND THAT WE ALL SHARE
DATA AND FINDINGS ABOUT THE
DISEASE AS WE TRY TO STOP ITS
SPREAD.
ALL OVER THE WORLD, WONDERFUL
AND BRAVE DOCTORS -- I’VE BEEN
ABLE TO TALK TO SOME OF THEM --
WHO ARE TREATING COVID-19
PATIENTS, ARE POSTING THEIR
FINDINGS ONLINE, YOU CAN READ
SOME OF THEM IN CHAT ROOMS WHERE
THE DOCTORS ARE TALKING TO EACH
OTHER.
IT’S FANTASTIC.
BUT WE NEED THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT TO GIVE US TOTAL AND
COMPLETE ACCESS TO ALL THEIR
SCIENTIFIC DATA, INCLUDING, BY
THE WAY, THE FINDINGS OF DOCTORS
WHO FIRST STUDIED AND DISCOVERED
THE VIRUS.
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION WAS
APPARENTLY DESTROYED.
WE WANT TO FIND IT.
WE WANT IT BACK.
WE WANT TO KNOW EVERYTHING ABOUT
PATIENT 0.
THE TRUE RECOVERY RATE, THE TRUE
MORTALITY RATE, INCLUDING THOSE
WHO WERE LOCKED IN THEIR
APARTMENTS AND LEFT TO DIE IN
WUHAN.
AND IF CHINA ISN’T WILLING TO
WORK WITH US, THINK ABOUT THIS,
IN DEFEATING THIS PANDEMIC COME
IN ENSURING THAT SOMETHING LIKE
THIS NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN?
LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TODAY.
STOCK HOLDINGS, 401(K)s, MANY
PEOPLE LOSING THEIR JOBS.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
IF YOU ARE NOT OPERATING IN
TOTAL TRANSPARENCY REGARDING
THIS DISEASE, THEN WE HAVE TO
ASK OURSELVES WHY WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO BE INTEGRATED WITH
THEM AT ALL, ON ANY ISSUE.
WE HAVE NOTHING AGAINST THE
CHINESE PEOPLE, JUST LIKE WE
DIDN’T HAVE ANYTHING AGAINST THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE DURING THE COLD
WILL OR, BUT PRESIDENT XI AND
HIS BUREAU HAVE TO COME
CLEAN OR
WE NEED TO RECONSIDER --
CONSIDER, FRANKLY, TAKING SEVERE
MEASURES AGAINST BEIJING.
WE NEED A NEW INDUSTRIAL POLICY,
MADE IN THE USA ALL THE WAY.
IF THEY DON’T COME CLEAN, WE
HAVE TO REVOKE CHINA’S MOST
FAVORED NATION STATUS FOR TRADE,
BAN CHINESE INVESTMENT IN THE
U.S.
WE HAVE TO STRICTLY LIMIT
CHINESE TRAVEL TO THE
UNITED STATES.
AND BY THE WAY, FORGET THAT
SECOND PHASE OF THE TRADE DEAL,
WE HAVE TO ADD TARIFFS.
THAT SHOULD GET THEIR ATTENTION,
DON’T YOU THINK?
NOT ONLY HAS CHINA THUS FAR
REFUSED TO ALLOW OUR TOP MEDICAL
OFFICIAL ACCESS TO ALL THE DATA,
ALL OF THE HOSPITALS, ALTHOUGH
PREMIER RESEARCHERS, THEY ARE
KICKING OUT OUR JOURNALIST!
WHO ARE ACTUALLY THERE TRYING TO
REPORT THE TRUTH ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED, GOING BACK TO
NOVEMBER, DECEMBER, JANUARY, AND
WHAT DIDN’T HAPPEN.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTING
THAT THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT CAST
ITS EXPULSION OF THE JOURNALISTS
AS NECESSARY TO DEFEND BEIJING
AGAINST WHAT IT PERCEIVED AS AN
IDEOLOGICAL CAMPAIGN ARE THE
UNITED STATES TO IMPOSE ITS
VALUES ON CHINA.
YEAH, THE VALUE OF TRUTH.
AND YET, DESPITE ALL OF THIS,
DESPITE WHAT HAS HAPPENED,
DESPITE HOW AWFUL THIS HAS
GOTTEN FOR PEOPLE ALL AROUND THE
WORLD, AND OF COURSE HERE,
SOMEHOW, SOMEHOW, THERE ARE
AMERICAN JOURNALISTS WHO ARE
STILL FRETTING ABOUT CHINA’S
FEELINGS.
>> WHY DO YOU KEEP CALLING THIS
CHINESE VIRUS?
WHY DO YOU KEEP USING THIS?
>> IT COMES FROM CHINA.
IT’S NOT RACIST AT ALL, NOT AT
ALL.
IT COMES FROM CHINA.
>> A PERSON AT THE WHITE HOUSE
USES "KUNG FLU"."
>> IN TALKING ABOUT CHINA,
YOU’VE BEEN CLEAR ABOUT WHO YOU
THINK THE BLAME OR WHERE YOU
THINK THE VERY KNOW MY CLAIM IS
FOR THIS FIRE IS --
>> I KNOW WHERE IT CAME FROM.
IT COMES FROM CHINA.
IT’S NOT A QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
>> Laura: GOOD FOR TRUMP.
OH, AND WHEN WE ARE NOT WORRIED
ABOUT THE VIRUS’ NOMENCLATURE,
WE APPARENTLY WANT TO HELP THE
ECONOMY OF THE COUNTRY
RESPONSIBLE FOR OUR NATIONAL
NIGHTMARE.
>> LOOKED, CHINA IS PAYING
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN TARIFFS AND THERE’S NO REASON
TO DO THAT, BUT WE ARE GETTING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS A YEAR FROM
TARIFFS IN CHINA, AND I CAN’T
IMAGINE AMERICANS ASKING FOR
THAT.
>> Laura: YEAH, WELL, THE
QUESTION WAS -- PEOPLE ARE
TELLING ME TO TAKE YOUR TARIFFS
ON CHINA NOW.
SHOULDN’T YOU DO THIS, GIVEN --
UNBELIEVABLE.
LOOK AT HOW MUCH TIME WAS LOST
BECAUSE CHINA COVERED IT UP AT
THE END OF LAST YEAR, COVERED UP
THE VIRUS.
THEY THREATENED DOCTORS, REFUSED
TO ALLOW INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
TEAMS INTO ASSESS THE SITUATION.
IN ITS HANDLING OF COVID-19 --
AND THIS IS GOING TO SOUND
TOUGH, BUT CHINA HAS BLOOD ON
ITS HANDS.
ONE RECENT STUDY FOUND THAT IF
CHINA HAD IMPLEMENTED ITS
CONTROL MEASURES A WEEK EARLIER,
IT COULD HAVE PREVENTED 67% OF
ALL CASES THERE!
IMPLEMENTING THE MEASURES THREE
WEEKS EARLIER, FROM THE
BEGINNING OF JANUARY, WOULD HAVE
CUT THE NUMBER OF INFECTIONS TO
5% OF THE TOTAL.
AND YET, THE W.H.O. WANTS
EVERYONE TO THINK THAT, WHAT, WE
ARE SUPPOSED TO FAWN OVER
CHINA’S CONTAINMENT EFFORTS?
THAT’S RIDICULOUS.
WE CANNOT SIT BY AND LET OUR
PEOPLE HAVE THEIR LIVES
THREATENED, OUR ENTIRE ECONOMY
DEVASTATED, NOT BY A CONTAGION
THAT ORIGINATED IN CHINA, A
COUNTRY THAT FUSES TO ALLOW THE
NIH UNFETTERED ACCESS.
I WAS MAKING ABOUT THIS TODAY,
FIRST OF ALL, HOW BLESSED I AM
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A JOB AND
KEEP WORKING DURING ALL OF THIS,
AND TO HAVE ALL OF YOU WATCHING
EVERY NIGHT.
HAVE MY HEALTH AND MY FAMILY’S
HEALTH.
BUT I THOUGHT ABOUT THE MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WHO
WORK THERE BUTTS OFF EVERY DAY
AND SEE THEIR DREAM -- THEIR
DREAM -- OF HAVING A RETIREMENT
SOMEDAY, PUT THEIR KIDS THROUGH
COLLEGE, VANISHED BECAUSE OF
THIS VIRUS.
MUCH, IF NOT ALL OF THIS, COULD
HAVE BEEN AVOIDED IF CHINA HAD
ONLY BEEN FORTHCOMING FROM DAY